alright it is time to go to the game
awards 2017 hello Edie where's Jenna
hello Jenna
hello suzi I'm very excited for the show
I'll be presenting today for an award
and it's a student award which is
actually really cool there's Matt we've
got Larry over there are you - oh you -
I want to say I love you guys first of
all I'm really excited to see you I've
not seen her in forever really sorry
have a great night were you sitting I'm
not sure I don't know either I didn't
we've got we know we're inside you're
gonna watch the you're gonna watch the
event we're gonna have some fun what do
you what are you hoping with grief and
punching not yet I'm waiting okay next
week next box walk like the biggest
names are here
tell me about your new League of Legends
team means you've seen took a photo
together we didn't want to cherish it
forever cool it's good out here
welcome to Twitter thank you so much
well can you look at work there welcome
to welcome you to Twitter yes after it
said we are alive like very soon as can
you make sure you're presenting good
luck I won't keep you but by spitting
into the theatre vlogging on my iPhone
today because I forgot an SD card and my
camera was dead two things to fail
here's Jenna hi Jenna
she's getting the drink
[Applause]
[Music]
the Game Awards Orchestra tonight this
is the show that we've always dreamed of
doing the game words they keep all so
much for joining us we are here to
celebrate the greatest storm ever taken
the world
that's video games in order to do it
style tonight
[Applause]
alive
[Music]
[Applause]
we're now backstage the game rewards
about to present and I'm so excited
because I present an ecstatic
okay he's only who that is you got to a
quick Google search because you will
immediately know he is so incredible and
he's avala in death too he's by far the
best voice actor
I just I'm such a huge fan I'm kind of
and girly right now and he was also
agent oils in French one of my favorite
shows ever so about that employer so
[Applause]
Vangelis from the show let's say clip
the world
the person that request
[Applause]
the winner and the beer selected by 51
mobile media news outlets and the fans
to be your newest to the legend of ZOA
[Applause]
the show is over it was so awesome
surprise game of the year was Zelda that
was who I was hoping for but it's such a
hard decision because I loved Super
Mario Odyssey so much we could have two
winners in my book we have a very
special performance coming up appreciate
this next artist flying in all the way
from Australia I think there dizzyland
right to be here tonight bass gentleman
Charli XCX
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's after the Game Awards and oh my
goodness he'll see hi so this is Yossi
and he is the sweetest little pup and
his best friend is me oh hi there so the
game Wars was so much fun Matt to have a
good time I had an absolute blast
cheeseburgers at the after-party what
more can I ask for show us your new lens
let's talk about it so it's a 16 by 35
2.8 Sony G master or my a 7s mark - so
is a 16 - yes
it's a 16 to 35 this lens is what
Justine and I have been using for many
many years now it's my favorite it's got
really great yeah it's a 4.0 though so
this has more depth it's summer it's
$2,100
but it's a great lens I'm very much
looking forward to trying it out but
it's very heavy weight let me hold it
let me see yeah do it it's so heavy and
look at his microphone he has what is
this is absurd it's a rechargeable
microphone no it's powered by its own
power source you charge this microphone
with a micro USB it's just rechargeable
Wow okay well I made fun of you but now
I'm gonna get one should we open up
Maddy's Christmas present so a lot of
you guys may know because most of the
jewelry that I wear is Tiffany's and I'm
a huge Tiffany's fan I've been a fan of
Tiffany's for basically ever they now
had dog collars Madi
Josie your present look it's in here
what's in Mandy you just want the ribbon
what's in here hey you're the worst
Christmas gift ever
well I guess I probably could have oh my
gosh still loving it well I think
mommy's more excited about this and
doggy well they're into the dream
official unboxing oh it's cute oh my god
beautiful Wow if they made this in a
bracelet for a human oh yeah I'm adding
you into it yes my prayer got tricked
this is only when you're dressing up and
wearing your fancy your Sunday finest oh
man that'd be cute if this could
customize to their own little tag -
pretty little information do you like it
say thank you Maddy you look handsome
little tighter
[Music]